[موسيقى]
الهند واسرائيل علاقه اتسمت بنوع من
القطيعه على مدى عقود ومرت بتحولات مليئه
بالتعقيدات والتعرجات ففي عام
1947 وخلال مناقشه الامم المتحده لقرار
تقسيم فلسطين عرضت الهند القرار ودعت الى
اقامه حكومه فلسطينيه فيدراليه يمنح
اليهود فيها حكما ذاتيا قبل نحو 50 عاما
فقط كانت الهند تمتنع عن ايفاد دبلوماسيين
الى اسرائيل وكان يحضر على تل ابيب ان
تفتح سفاره لها في العاصمه دلهي واقتصرت
العلاقات نتيجه ذلك من جهه اسرائيل فقط
على المستوى القنصلي فافتتحت قنصليه لها
في مومباي باربعه موظفين وصفت مهمتهم
بانها المهمه الديبلومات الاكثر انعزالا
في العالم هذه العلاقه تحولت اليوم الى
علاقات استراتيجيه ولكن ذلك لم يحدث بين
يوم
وليله بدات العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
اسرائيل والهند في عام
1992 بعد عام واحد فقط من انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي الذي تسبب في تراجع روسيا عالميا
فيما يتعلق بتصدير الاسلحه في وقت كانت
فيه الصناعات العسكريه الامريكيه ما تزال
بعيده عن السوق الهندي ولذلك اراد دلهي
الدخول في علاقات جديده مع طرف يمكنه ان
يسد لها تلك الثغره فما كان منها الا ان
ارتمت في احضان اسرائيل التي كانت تسعى
بدورها منذ قيامها لتوطيد علاقات مع الدول
الكبرى لادراك يقينا ان بقائها وسط محيط
لا يرحب بها لن يكون سوى من خلال
التحالفات الاستراتيجيه مع دول عظمى
ازدهرت العلاقات الثنائيه بين الهند
واسرائيل مع وصول حزب بهارتي جناتا الى
الحكم عام
1998 وتنوعت لترتكب التجاريه والاقتصاديه
والتكنولوجيه بالاضافه الى الانترنت
والسيارات الكهربائ
وتحليه المياه والادوات التحليليه
للمختبرات والتعليم الالي وامتدت لتشمل
خططا لتعظيم الامكانات التجاريه حتى صارت
الهند الثالث اكبر شريك تجاري اسيوي
لاسرائيل منذ عام
2014 وعاشر اكبر شريك تجاري على مستوى
العالم وبلغ حجم تجاره البلدين البينيه
نحو خه مليارات دولار في عام
2021 مقارنه ب 200 مليون دولار فقط عند
استئناف العلاقات مطلع
التسعينيات تعد الهند اكبر مشتر للمعدات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه التي تشكل نحو
49% من مجمل وارداتها العسكريه التي بلغت
قيمتها 15 مليار دولار اضافه الى ان
اسرائيل ثاني اكبر مورد دفاعي للهند بعد
روسيا يشمل الدعم العسكري الاسرائيل للهند
توليد كميات كبيره من السلاح والوسائل
التكنولوجيه ذات الاستخدامات العسكريه
كالطائرات المسيره ووسائل قتاليه متطوره
جدا وادوات رؤيه ليليه وجدران الكترونيه
لتحسين الرقابه على الحدود الهنديه اضافه
الى الذخيره والصواريخ والمضادات الجويه
والارضيه الى جانب التدريبات العسكريه
المشتركه على المستوى الامني تتعاون دوله
الاحتلال استخباراتيا مع دلهي وشاركت في
تصميم النظريه الامنيه الهنديه في صراعها
مع باكستان وتقدم لها معلومات عن نشطاء في
باكستان المجاوره وتتحدث التقارير عن دور
السلاح الاسرائيلي المفصلي في الاشتباكات
وان القصف الهندي لبعض المواقع
الباكستانيه كان بصواريخ اسرائيليه كما
تردد اسم اسرائيل في مواجهات نيو دلهي
واسلام اباد في ظل ح زه الهند لمنظومه
سبايدر الاسرائيليه التي تولت حمايه
اجوائها من عمليات التجسس
الباكستانيه مع انطلاق عمليه طوفان الاقصى
في السابع من اكتوبر
2013 اعلنت حكومه نيو دلهي وقوفها الى
جانب اسرائيل موقف بدا مغايرا لما سارت
عليه الهند من الصراع العربي الاسرائيلي
في السابق ويعزى السبب في ذلك الى تفاقم
القوميه الهندوسيه في البلاد وجهود
الحكومه في الحفاظ على علاقات جيده مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ايا كان الثمن
بالاضافه الى مشروع الممر الاقتصادي بين
الهند والخليج واوروبا والذي اعربت الهند
عن قلقها من تاثره بالحرب الاسرائيليه على
[موسيقى]
غزه
l